In 17th century-Europe terrible events were
affecting Jewish communities: The Thirty Years
War, the Cossack revolt, and massacres of
the Jewish people.
They were also accused of “blood libel,”
or the ritual murder of Christian children.
They needed a redeemer, a symbol of hope.
So they turned back to their folklore and
to the Golem.
This mud and earth-formed humanoid creature
turns up in many tales, and not only in Jewish
but non-Jewish stories.
Golem stories have survived over time, persisting in written and oral folklore
But it was during time of genocide and war that the story of the golem holds the most significance
In Jewish folklore, there are three reasons
to create a golem: as a way to show one’s
mastery of the Kabbalah, to have a trustworthy
and dependable servant for labor, or to provide
protection for the Jewish community.
You’ve likely seen a golem, even if you
didn’t recognize it at the time.
He’s taken lots of different forms in recent
years, inspiring characters in The Simpsons,
Pokémon, Dungeons and Dragons, Arthur, and
even the X-Files, but golems can be traced
back to 6th century Jewish culture.
He’s old.
Old as dirt.
The Golem story most widely known is the early
20th century version of the Golem of Prague.
In it, Rabbi Loew asked the Heavens how to
stop the persecution of his community, and
he received an answer— make a Golem.
To do this he seeks the help of two other
rabbis, each “born with” the power of
one of the four elements.
The rabbis represented air, fire, and water.
Clay collected from the river served as the
earth element.
The rabbis take the clay and shape the form
of a man.
They each walk around the form counterclockwise
seven times, reciting special letters.
The body begins to glow and vapors rise from
the form.
The golem opens
his eyes—now a living thing.
The Golem of Prague is named Yosef and looks
human but cannot speak.
Rabbi Loew tells the golem he was created
to guard the Jewish people from their enemies.
Yosef has supernatural strength and can become
invisible with the help of a special amulet.
He completes many tasks serving as a watchman,
rescuing a kidnapped girl, and even summoning
a dead woman.
The Golem of Prague is only one version of
the golem.
Others have existed for thousands of years.
One could be brought to life by a Jewish scholar,
usually a rabbi, and God’s name is required
in some way to actually bring it to life.
You can animate a golem by reciting the proper
letters of God’s name, placing God’s name
into the golem’s mouth, affixing it to the
forehead, or by placing the Hebrew word for
“truth” into the clay body.
To understand why the golem is created from
dirt, first we have to take a quick look at
another creation story.
One found in the Torah, the foundational text
of Judaism.
There it is said that God created Adam, the
first man, by forming him from the dust of
the earth and breathing life into him.
Jewish scholars developed the Golem legend
based on the Adam creation story.
Historians point to a section of the Talmud,
where a rabbi created an artificial man who
was like any other, except he could not speak
- for only God could give that power, which
explains why all traditional variations of
the golem are mute.
In later versions, the creature becomes dangerous
or hard to control because it gains power
the longer it is animated, or it simply takes
direction too literally.
Looking back to the Golem of Prague, perhaps
the singular most important character in these
stories, even more so than the golem himself,
is Rabbi Loew, a real person and noted leader
of the Jewish community in the 16th Century.
Interestingly, Loew himself didn’t believe
in miracles, condemned magic, and never wrote
about the golem.
But In 1909, a manuscript supposedly written
by Rabbi Loew’s son-in-law was “discovered”
by Orthodox Rabbi Yudl Rosenberg - though
it’s generally agreed that this document
never existed.
He then published his version of the Golem
of Prague which became one of the most important
Golem legends.
The 1ate 19th Century was the first time the
Golem became not just a means of labor, but
a protector of the Jewish people.
Throughout the 19th century, there were multiple
cases of blood libel, an antisemitic accusation
that claims a Jewish person ritualistically
murdered a Christian, usually a child.
Rabbi Rosenberg was all too familiar with
this.
There was a blood libel case near Prague in
1899, as well as organized violence against
the Jewish people in Russia at the turn of
the twentieth century.
It makes sense that he would portray the golem
in his story as a protector at a time when
his people really needed one.
In 1917, The Golem: Legends of the Ghetto
of Prague, the next popular text featuring
Rabbi Loew, was published.
The Jewish author was part of the community
forced to relocate to the interior of Austria
after the Russian invasion.
Although similar to Rosenberg’s version,
in this golem story, Rabbi Loew is forced
to destroy the golem, here named Joseph, because
he becomes a danger to the entire city.
Nevertheless, the story ends with the golem
waiting in the attic of a synagogue in Prague
to be reawakened the next time persecuted
Jews need protecting.
The increase in Jewish migration throughout
the twentieth-century helped spread the golem
story.
We’ve seen it in movies, ballet, children’s
books, and comics.
But in each new version, it has continued
to change form.
The original goal of creating a Golem was
to make something more powerful than yourself.
In most cases this was not done to oppress
or control anyone, but to give the creator
and their community agency, even freedom.
What began as a way to demonstrate mastery
of a religious text, morphed into an unintended
monster, and was later reclaimed as a protector.
Golem’s story is as malleable as the clay
from which it was formed